journée de mobilisation soutenue par
l'île de france et par l'urss le sport
scolaire était organisée aujourd'hui
dans toutes les îles de loisirs de la
région pour soutenir la candidature de
paris aux jeux olympiques de 2024 à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines plus de 700
jeunes venus de tout le département pour
participer à des animations sportives
l'opération a été baptisée sobrement
jo-2000 24 au programme initiation à des
raids découverte des activités
olympiques tels que le canoë le biathlon
ou encore le vtt on écoute quelques
réactions au micro de michael et demi
d'euros cet événement montre la jeune
génération est engagée pour paris 2024
et nous donne un maximum de chance de
montrer au monde que cette jeune
génération francilienne croit aux jeux
parce que c'est son avenir
c'est son développement qui est en jeu
et nous nous voulons que ces jeux ci
soit les jeux de cette nouvelle
génération
évidemment parce que c'est la génération
qui sera la génération des athlètes de
2024 mais aussi parce que cette
génération construit une île de france
de demain